l'anglais c'est facile du petit des mots
ensemble ça fait une phrase le français
il faut savoir un petit peu où on s'en
va dans notre phase et soyez c'est ici
que avec différents élections aux
provinciaux d'avoir un meilleur prix et
ses curés et assurer les emplois
justin trudeau ont souvent critiqué pour
la qualité de son français
c'est vrai il fait parfois des fautes
non sens surtout qu'ils cherchent
souvent ces mots c'est moi je le suis
vraiment selon plusieurs linguistes ses
hésitations son reflet d'un certain
malaise en français un manque d'aisance
quand beaucoup de franco ontarien où
franco albertain bref les francophones
en milieu minoritaire
je crois que je sais trudeau reprise des
concours minoritaire avec sa prestation
du français
je m'identifie définitivement avec le
français parlé de justin trudeau je
pense qui par leur français qui est pas
prétentieux nous venons tous est tout
juste de conclure c'est un francophone
sont on en voit tous les jours
à l'extérieur du québec et peut-être
même au québec quand justin trudeau
s'exprime en français
il semble démontrer un certain malaise
c'est plus rigide moins communicatif
justin trudeau on voit qu'ils pensent à
sa langue qu'ils parlent français
on boit pas de compétence ce sens il
paraît qu'à natif parce que si
j'arrivais à brébeuf à montréal en sont
onéreux j'ai eu beaucoup de misère au
début j'avais des mauvaises habitudes en
français je faisais des erreurs
évidentes et garder des fois des des
échos d'avoir été dans une ville plutôt
anglophone dans mon jeune âge
quelques je parle des fois je fais la
même hésitation que monsieur triaud fait
avec le a et le e
mais c'est surtout à cause de trouver de
bons mots
moi je me représente comme francophones
mais la langue auxquels il est plus
facile que j'aime extrême site en
anglais j'ai un homme québécois puis
souvent ses parents vont essayer de me
corriger et ça ça me sépare un peu de
les autres je trouve ça un peu énervant
dix fois il vient des jeunes
francophones en milieu minoritaire le
dise il semble que leur france est
scrutée à la loupe qu'on entend plus
leur erreur que celle d'un québécois par
exemple et ça ça renforce leur malaise
je pense que il y à une pression encore
plus forte sur les francophones enceinte
est minoritaire de parler un français
parfait
sinon si on parlait un français qui est
exceptionnel on se fait dire qu'on est
anglophone ou qu'est en train de se
faire assimiler ou par un parent qui
n'est pas du tout le corps parfois on
devrait on devrait laisser la chance aux
gens de pratiquer leur procès sans
jugement et sans son son et patient
parce que leur français n'est pas passé
digne de molière le français est une des
langues les plus normatives dans le
monde c'est-à-dire une langue où les
gens et français en particulier sont
obsédés par la correction de la langue
ils vont te corriger les cantons
francophones minoritaires étaient pas
trop sûr pas l'impression que ce
correcteur là et toujours autour de toi
par contre c'est au québec déjà eu ce
même malaise cette même insécurité
linguistique et par rapport à la france
ce qui a fait en sorte que les québécois
se sont sentis plus confiants dans leur
langue depuis les années 60
c'est en trop la promotion du français
cette promotion de l'image du français
contrairement au québec s'est arrêté à
mon avis au canada anglophone où le
gouvernement fédéral a cessé de faire de
la publicité comme envoyait on envoyait
le long des routes et à la télévision
que le canada était un pays fier de son
bilinguisme
bien sûr la sécurité que ressentent
certains francophones en milieu
minoritaire ne va pas disparaître du
jour au lendemain mais selon françois
paris les francophones il pourrait
devenir plus confiants dans leur langue
s'ils étaient plus respectés coûts
soutenue et donc à son avis justin
trudeau a un rôle important à jouer
là-dedans qui pourrait faire la
promotion du français à l'extérieur du
québec
il ya rien de plus magique que la voix
gouvernement fédéral canadien qui dit
c'est comme ça qu'on se voie du centre
bilingue il ya des francophones et des
anglophones et l'idéal c'est que tout le
monde parle la langue de tout le monde
[Musique]